bruxelles capitale de l'europe capitale
de la frite capitale du manneken pis
mais aussi de la new beat and you vite
la new beat verdâtre européen de la
house américaine est née ici il y à
faire dans les allées où la saos quelle
haine parce qu'à une escale ce bidon
moyennant 12 francs le bus les emmène
s'éclater à 15 km de l'île un véritable
pèlerinage pour s'offrir la nouvelle
fièvre du samedi soir aux cayes line le
temple du newbie ce nouveau hit mené en
belgique les langes terriblement dansant
le sans emprunter à droite à gauche soit
publicitaire du bistrot y même discours
politique d'abord un sou le novice est
aujourd'hui une mode voire un phénomène
sociologique le plus important depuis
l'ère disco et si la jeune génération à
trouver une nouvelle identité musicale
de new big c est aussi et surtout un
commerce juteux
deuxième principe de la musique c'est
d'être sexy le sexe est partout dans les
paroles qu'il abhorre réduite à quelques
onomatopées qui vous transportera dans
le tas fox en 1ere communion entre les
sexes est possible dans les pays où l'on
voit deux jeunes hommes adeptes de
matrone van bouwel dans orange mécanique
de menthe et sur quelques jeunes filles
peu farouches plus appréciés pour leur
tour de poitrine que leur quotient
intellectuel à la new beat fait
aujourd'hui danser des milliers de
jeunes dans toutes les discothèques
d'europe du nord les jeunes qui n'ont
pas grand chose à dire sans grande
conviction
mais pour qui la new beat est devenu non
pas une philosophie mais un art de vivre
être new beat c'est être acide c'est
être fun
exposition